we're being called to assemble by The
Vindicator I refuse to answer a literal
call to adventure Morty let it go to
voicemail Rick of indicators only call
when the universe itself is at stake
so the first line of defense against
evil they're the guardians of the
unguarded or the writers of their own
press releases Morty they're a bunch of
drama queens it's been an hour talking
and 20 minutes jumping around while [ __ ]
blows up they're a phase we did one it
was the big event of that summer let it
die hi Morty Smith invoke my right to
choose one in every 10 Rick and Morty
ensures freedom and we've been damn it
fine but don't say I didn't warn you
yeah Vindicator command ship beacon
received we're doing Vindicator Stu
whoops Morty you might want to free some
sperm new Rick and Morty let's break it
down and there is a new round of that
merch giveaway too all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video it's for Zen
monkey studios so they were pretty on
the nose with a lot of their references
they even mentioned the Saw movies
during it but it starts out like a
parody of a marvel guardians of the
galaxy Avengers infinity war movie with
some Justice League Easter eggs then it
turns into the Saw movie and even though
I didn't think it was the strongest
episode I did feel like they had a
couple really awesome things like I
always appreciate it when they take
shots at the Marvel movies there was
even some Star Wars in there like noob
noob is very clearly a parody on the Jar
Jar Binks character just like the
ridiculous characters that no one is
sure why they're around but always
laughs at everyone's jokes and is always
super positive they were spared having
to see their grown son wear a whistle ah
damn
thanks noob noob this guy gets it I'm
nervous about my first mission actually
noob noob you have a new mission one of
the best moments in the episode was when
we find out that it wasn't Morty that
Rick was doing this all for it was for
noob noob because he didn't call him out
at that meeting the episode continued
the extended streak of poop jokes when
Rick basically just craps himself all
over the table here that was great he
even craps himself in the middle of that
broadcast when he's taping himself for
noob noob so if anybody's friends with
Dan Harmon Justin Royal and just make
sure they're doing okay there just
seemed to be a lot of poop jokes this
season so we can guess what the poop
joke is going to be in next
week's episode there were a bunch of big
guest stars you probably recognized the
biggest ones Christian Slater was pretty
easy to recognize his Maximus renegade
star soldier very clearly their star
Lord Ironman parody like you sort of
wearing his tech suit any sort of
Cramer's himself through all these
situations like outfit gives us out even
though I'm drinking in a really funny
way Gillian Jacobs was playing their
star sapphire character she was sort of
a Captain Marvel Star Sapphire analog
like her power came from a collapsing
star so that's why she says our baby
died inside my womb because it was half
a million ants in half collapsing star
so she's the one that goes off the rails
and then slings away at the end of the
episode we'll talk about the end of the
episode because I wasn't super happy
with the way they ended the story Lance
Reddick played ghost train you might
remember him from The Wire he's done a
bunch of other TV series and then logic
guest-starred at the end as himself
playing at the party that Rick threw
when he got super drunk ghost train was
more of a Green Lantern parody and then
obviously million ants is a parody of
ant-man and grew at the same time like
he is a man made of ants even though
there's a queen inside him there there
were even a lot of you that thought that
million ants was going to be like a poop
man like literally made out of poop Rick
did make that joke he literally tells
them that he looks kind of like poop
world Endor was sort of an analogue for
Galactus Thanos darkside like all the
biggest cosmic Justice League villains
even though Rick wound up being the
biggest villain of the episode Rick has
the joke about the Marvel phases we did
one last summer it was a phase let it
die they're the authors of their own
press releases just talking about how
Marvel and DC just hype up all their own
projects like they're the best things on
the planet but when the team is talking
about their second big Avengers team-up
they talk about doom DeMott ron's
they're talking about Ultron so it's
like then telling Morty he missed
Avengers age of Ultron Marvel phase 2
now he's back for phase 3 and infinity
war lady katana Calypso Diablo Verde
they're all just meant to be funny
twists on Avengers characters that are
super forgettable and that's the whole
point of the episode that Rick's trying
to prove through this saw game is that
they're all completely interchangeable
with pretty much all the same
backstories in all the
same qualities like none of them are
particularly special he even calls out
Crocky bot for being super redundant
half cold unfeeling robot half cold
unfeeling reptile so you may have also
spotted this too is that their roster
actually looks very similar to the
roster of ball fondlers' like look at
this here you have a noob noob you have
a crocodile you have a really big huge
black dude and you have the crazy
hardcore female character in fun fact 2
ball fondlers' started out as a parody
of Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles but for
legal reasons I think they had to change
it into something that was a little more
general and then on top of that noob
noob also kind of looked like a mentally
handicapped version of mr. poopy
butthole even though his voice was kind
of the same I think that was more
coincidence because Justin royal can
only do so many voices so a lot of the
voices in the background for characters
that don't wind up popping up too much
end up sounding the same as really big
characters and if you look in the
background of the party scene there are
a bunch of characters from previous
episodes like Rick says that people try
to kill me every week that's why he lets
the star sapphire character get away and
then you cut to Rivoli o clock bird Jr
who did try to kill Rick and then a
bunch of other characters in the
background from previous episodes that
also tried to kill Rick one of the best
things about this background shot though
is that you see world ender and it looks
like somebody's trying to use him in a
weekend at bernie's scheme but like he's
clearly dead we saw his guts spilled
everywhere in the episode but you see
him here in a weekend at Bernie's outfit
in the background so either this guy or
somebody else just brought into the
party to try and get in or something
like that but let me know in the
comments which are the characters from
previous episodes or other cartoon shows
do you spot in the background here this
even almost looks like Morty's son here
in the background I don't think it's him
though
but overall even though they had a lot
of great jokes in the episode and I did
like the idea of them trying to take a
shot at Marvel and DC in the comic book
movies there are a lot of bad big
comic-book movies and they're not wrong
about some of the tropes that they call
out in this I feel like the plot just
really wasn't that great and they didn't
quite stick the landing either in that
whole party at the end just felt
completely out of place but there was a
really strong concept for the episode
but they didn't have a really good way
of leading it along like I fell apart as
they
along and it almost felt like they
didn't have a solid idea for the ending
so like in the writers room they're
sitting there like what do we do to end
the episode why don't we just end it in
a totally random party so Rick
apparently does all these things while
he's drunk
which I guess is believable but bigger
conspiracy theory they did the bad
ending at the end like the big party
ending is a way to parody the bad
endings of a lot of big comic book
movies where everything ends in this big
celebration
despite through their actions during the
episode they almost wind up killing each
other and dying so they should be
freaking out like at the end of the cold
open from episode 6 where they're just
sitting there breaking down crying oh my
god why do we do this to ourselves
[Music]
anymore seriously um we almost died oh
you agree yes that this was insane that
was pure luck
I was not in control of that situation
at all that should be how they end this
episode not the party but if you spotted
any other big Easter eggs that I didn't
mention in the video just write them
below in the comments and let me know
what you thought of the episode
I feel like this probably won't wind up
being their strongest episode this
season but it was still a lot of fun so
what's going to happen is I'll name the
giveaway winner when I post my episode 5
trailer video that'll be tomorrow while
you wait for everything you can click
here for my episode 3 Easter Egg video
and you can click here for my episode 2
Easter eggs thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
you
[Music]
[Applause]